you like to start everyone good evening
welcome right I with the noticed if I
may so can I ask everyone to notice that
these 20 movie audio recording in fact
he's being bi recorded right should be
required to evacuate the building would
you please leave the room by the doors
to the fire escape staircase please hold
both handrails in case the stairs or wet
or slippery if anyone is unable to use
the stairs where they please allow
others to exit the room floor they go
into the forest gate door where they can
the immediate assistance our a 70-point
will be in the public car park at the
side of the Civic sweet please do not
delay your evacuation to collect any
belongings and please do not return to
building until given permission to do so
by council staff right good evening
everyone what we've got a reasonably
full agenda so let's make a start so
apologies for absence of apologies from
Joan person I think that's the only one
is it yes I things first but non members
attending and welcome to children oh I
know I mean it's in the meeting held on
the second December is it your wish I
sign them as a true record really any
declarations of interest please why
shouldn't interest come to your occur
during the meeting please give it to us
then when my penis animated masses refer
to the executive and reports formalities
there are none so we go straight to item
6 please progress on decisions made by
for counsel item 6 start at the
beginning pleased to see there's a lot
of these things that have been completed
I suppose at this time of year they
should be really right first item we've
got is under 63 devolution but if
anybody wants to speak to that all at
the moment it's some sort of an advance
and two after the elections now and
that's the way it's going so but there
are still some things going on in the
background anybody else want to speak on
that ok next one I have
going forward is page 69 ICT provision
support contract and workers in progress
no comments on that well an item 10
nothing casual we've drawn that one yet
mouths that they are really relating to
the provision of public toilets be
removed from the general thank you okay
degree three AK butter there's 10 and 11
isn't it alright so item 13 County
highways range of functions yes please
we just go back sorry to whine some
verses point in 11 it was just query the
aligners of curb also other that's buddy
l about my apologies okay modern ad
Alliance occurred you to a change in our
wise contractors management for someone
you large on that place yeah I thought I
can only return though how do you manage
on site and so it's just a delay in
getting about price of crime together to
continue that sir service and then the
discussion the logistics it was also I
didn't want to use a previous through an
arrangement only seem fair to let them
have a new manager had an affair sort of
the crack what he thought was it was the
right price and everything else to
deliver okay oh there thank you thank
you right over this item 6 13 count I
was range of functions I hot sure we are
we that let's go first after you
thankies legs hurt so much m Thank You
chairman basically I struggled to
understand what I do these days
so that the reason that I have had an
issue of late with the resident I was 77
years of age with embassy Mia he said
very threatening letters from Essex
County Council a scan indicates hedge
cut which isn't encroaching on my way
and when the highway Rangers were
approached to help they said jobs to big
food so it's too big for them is to be
for 77 year old is famously Mia so I'm
kind of struggle where we go with that
Thank You chairman it's the
responsibility whoever is the owner of
the property I think that's the girl
which is sanitary housing sanctuary so
same old site century housings
responsibility and i believe that essex
county council have now send the
gentleman in question and apology
because of Todd and their letters which
I think was anything I'm pleased to hear
that because they know it's not so
Leslie what's going to resonate in
anything I'm sure there are better ways
in fact I know for a fact that county is
looking at the way they write some of
their letters tourism here as well come
as a consequence it is but other than
others we work hopefully take forward
right and you want to give lately I
think it's actually on the last
paragraph where the progress reports
going down further meetings are being
able with ECC to provide better
clarification with the agreement before
proceeding I just wondered where we were
on that and how we are proceeding is
there any update on what we have in
front of us yes yeah actually I would
anticipate on within the month we should
have something fun that really good can
I ask what will be fine
the grim the TV you had perused before
and to anything years he enters the eye
operator but so it would be an you're
brilliant it's just the clarifier if you
like existing Arrangements on the
payments we receive can it be
retrospective fragments you're referring
to the receipt that we have for what we
do for them not the Rangers absolutely I
think you refer some range why apologies
yes yes happens a little to discuss the
range of showing as far as I'm desert
it's stuffed because of juubi yes any
movement now Ted well it will move on I
take it as a staff it's really
undercounting in that sense so now does
it aren't you a question sorry I'm not
happening no it's been there / 18 months
I'm sure sit there for an unraced team
he's crazy nothing to do as we can't do
the guys up so so realistically there's
we're still tent we are at present yes
it's mine girl is another contract early
Israelites at the end of tunnel before
they ask I always optimistic a chimney
variables without the other thing
without seeing that there is a meeting
later this month with senior management
from expect accounts also and let that
that's one of the issues that we will be
able to assess good is that the meeting
we're invited to the SS yes how good it
was alright
right going on to 614 cutie safety hub
is please don't if we have we got on
basically and we're going to talk it in
mind which will measure the success of
this particular and one put it trial
period there's a trial period that's
involved is there any any kind of
measurement we we're looking at to see
how successful it is in this trial
period have we set any parameters any
targets will think it's early days for
that but it's a good point that you
raise yes I think it's something that
should you know be followed through this
we can do that problem there's nothing
tangible it's very much the intangible
does it work does it not work there a
better feeling around it that's where it
currently is of the month ok but if
we've got some sort of idea where we're
going it helps to see if we haven't got
there at this point we've got one member
of staff that we're looking to transport
when we started this process there were
five and we're down where women's track
them removed one post okay and Castle
feedback on the freedom of information
statistics nothing there's too much on
that is it no right I did notice a lot
of these um when it seemed to have many
262 on them I don't know why even though
they were completely different that they
were right attendance at royal garden
party that's why there's too many
questions on that
really your snot yes but so is by the
johor mine since we do for our it your
671 jr. doesn't puzzle might go through
looks like I probably can we understand
announced an issue that right where are
we hopefully especially items building
works in the report big bleep fun
different 20,000 specializes budget and
now between confident new props for that
new railing any questions no right see
if I can go to the nickel after this no
there's the 16 light backline
resurfacing I think that's all in hand
there is yeah always one NT shop
strategy provide with the growth
strategy with that that person has grown
since launching 13 to London Road rally
which is I think it's kiss coated and
yet there's always new artist goes with
this with it yes okay so we can't do
much so now then right pilot minty
vehicle scheme and play spaces
refurbishment programme which things is
dead won't anyone is then okay any
quality management area roadie town
center I just for isha asking
about this one maybe because I wasn't
sure because the public health aspect it
comes in to my area but it's clearly
employment services and my understanding
is that the and the information I've got
that the questions are being asked
around has the 30 festive january
deadline be met for the action plan and
line study is that that's actually not
quite the right information there so the
comments on progress are inaccurate in
the junk that January 2016 was an
internal target to preserve members with
draft area action Kwan tiara action plan
the anchor which could then go on public
consultation later so the wording that
that is saying that there should be an
action plan by 30 festive January is not
not actually life my understanding is
that essex county council need to
commission it first and then
in fact today being information received
from Essex that enables that to go
forward okay thanks thanks for that but
I mean it shouldn't really be green
either should have now Mike but anyway
because if Dell is a great night please
determine it was interesting paste on
the television yeah yeah I saw it yeah
the question they were asking they're
discussing was who is the responsible
organization to do with this is a
government is it councils I don't where
are you it's a very good question I mean
how our our only remit is to monitor
clearly if there were a planning
application in the area and I think that
would be given as evidence if you like
for that kind of planning application as
you know so how that would proceed other
than that I don't think there's what we
can do is they don't chew mean i think
is very thorny somewhat loaded question
here but perhaps some in a more
seriously and admit we couldn't really
get the environmental health officer
who's responsible for dealing with this
to perhaps providing a briefing notes or
species Sunni
super valuable do okay yeah hbu members
thank you all right it seems to be that
one there where you know I play spaces
program which is Percy 226 there you go
good bye bye override diversity of
seating system scheme sorry funny to say
yeah offsetting scheme and that's all
road development ahead with an hectare
cherry orchard which is really good yes
is there any movement was this was
something that I spoke about and
obviously it's moved across to another
or ashamed isn't it between myself and
another Directorate maybe we're just
awaiting some sort of a clarification
Elena's planet has gone where the funds
have gone well it this is more of an
instrument that has been get details in
it absolutely sort of long it's not it's
not come to US soil so we're asking of
the conferencing that has this educated
range and has it gone directly with all
of that bank robbing ourselves
clarification I don't think it's being
released yet so your honor it was on the
commencement of the pentland that it was
meant to be released so we saying have
you actually done that yet aside please
confirm and then we can then draw down
calm that Monica thank you okay any
other questions buy one item seven then
this is the report from our wat by one
officer on water three financial
management report pleased to see that
we're 85,000 in the black on there which
is good news did you will say anything
on this place silent I thought I think
Mac members of our chance to have looked
through their City look let me say a
positive position going forward but
obviously we know going forward has got
a lot of challenges and we need to be
taken forward every bit of additional
income and savings that there's possible
we've got some summer items in the
captain program where the spending
hasn't been quite as much as planned or
is not been able to progress as we've
previously mentioned in some of the
budget setting process we're looking to
gather up that unspent capital to back
up reserves and start with our new
capital already agreed capital spending
plan into the next into the next year as
as a couple of eagle-eyed have spotted
there is a slide bracket error in some
of the tables that's simply an error
right really place I did I looking good
oh all those people can you break it was
me that was here okay the ones I was
think you know that i don't think the
additional bracket detracts from the
understanding of they have that I guess
I mean the point is there will be some
you know there's a lot of budgets
budgets in within the particular of this
and some will be up and some will be
down
and that is the normal thing as long as
it's actually following the tracks if
you like you know that's that's the good
thing about this but clearly you need to
keep a weather eye on all of the budgets
to make sure that you need that they're
following what's more or less watch for
cars and I very much only those that may
be overspending or getting to the stage
where they are overspending seeming at
how we can do that there will always be
slippage shutting within any capital
program there always will be because of
circumstances but it's making sure that
we've actually got enough capital to
spend on the projects that we want to
spend it on and I think that's the point
you know that links needs to be
clarified any other comments please or
any questions from anybody on that one
all right so we've been asked all of
three budget and capital position of the
council contained in section 3 and 4 and
as shown in appendix 1 to be approved
the reason for variations the previous
approve budgets as detailed in section 3
will be noted and then if we noted the
latest net revenue forecasts out turn is
expected to be eight point six eight
million for the 2015-16 as outlined in
paragraph 3 1 and eighty-five thousand
pound phoneable movement from quarter to
members happy with that you're thinking
a bigot doesn't
alright oh sorry yeah and the key
financial performance indicators current
financial performance on key revenue
financial indicators as shown in section
6 at appendix 3 be noted nice it right i
didn't realize those thought that was a
different thing but you're right is
under the broad heading decision being
recommended yeah thanks John clattering
right item 8 then my own patch which is
the University neighborhood area
application as members know we take
responsibility for any neighborhood
planning I believe that the money
doesn't actually come from ICS he comes
from the government he comes from yeah
so that's being past 42 cross and I
think the only area of conjecture was
around wallasey Island wasn't it if
anybody wants to comment on that at all
I understand their objection but it is
part of the area but they may well be
things that are coming along with in
that own development that would have
planning aspects to them in the future
it needs to be part of that planning
area so as far as the decision is
concerned are you ok to approve this
nimbus if it's not okay
so I 29 is 10th annual meetings i think
this cover that with amendments on that
John I think you can go to the next
slide yeah check chairman on page nine
point three verses a type i wobbled
towards better terminology under a
product but what October it's got
standards that should actually been
showing against 28 percept end up on the
time table so that will be moved to the
28 sorry the twenty-seven percent 10 x
27 Tuesday and the only other one again
the December the very top it's got
review and executive they should be
showing on the 29 from 35th November
they're not showing dates at the moment
that's where they should be so subject
of that chairman there is another one I
don't believe we have district elections
you someone I'm sorry forgive me I have
said anything come on oh you Miss good
old Mac start with our fix your buddy on
election yes yes catalyst yeah I mean
who knows what's gonna happen future but
I shall now be about right but I doing
chairman if that's I can have a query or
budget way dice I did briefly talk to
you about this a lot no I've spoken to
about it I am concerned the amount of
work has to go through we had to go
through on this budget y dime and it was
for the executive is a little bit more
easier because we have more meetings and
I don't think it's there another members
remember we had to get through on the
last two in particular the last budget
who I don't so I'd quite like there
another morning another Saturday morning
book in there someone if that's at all
possible your proposals to have instead
of having a full day was to have two
half days was there three number three
in total if you have ran off dine on too
yeah I don't think so no master taking
yeah I think accordingly though you were
making was it is a lot to take in is
rushed you know and you know there's
quite a lot there thanks for some
Russians please I with wheat had made us
before my opinion are not clearly we
even take that forward and have separate
discussions like that I'm happy to do
that obviously it's what I by now anyway
each other forward this has to go I
think to you for Piazza does it matter
it's a bit of a mixed thing showing I
mean in terms of the away day that that
can discussions could continue this is
really just about the committee's yeah
annual council will have to agree its
own dates but they are set out here move
reflecting annual council agenda and
again each committee in the new year
could change this but this just sets the
scene for the members and officers to to
start the business process of your name
okay I'm recorders about splitting over
three our phrase it's two reasons no
lunge this is what's concerning and but
more till that's going what are the
point there'll be an author of our
members can't make those three week half
days and therefore they will be losing
out even more than they lost out this
time I'm of the opinion that if we got
paper versions a week ahead not on
Pharisee morning or wherever it was bad
before but plenty of time ahead then we
can read them in as our leisure
understand them and come equipped with
the questions and that's my personal
view but if you start spending over
several weeks half days you're not going
to get everyone at all three therefore
gonna end up and less if you're heavy
and they were with just a hoodie that's
my opinion but I think we need the paper
much earlier than we headed last time
that's my view previous use we have
about the papers this um yeah so the
previous years has been very different
than yes the variable Babel or something
this case you're right but it is a
different kettle of fish now and there
was an awful lot of information being
provided and in my opinion you need to
sit down in a darkened room or with real
life on the wine and and take time to
understand what's being presented then
go to the verbal presentation because
you're equipped to receive that
information was far too much on the day
you just can't absorb it I can't
a smiley you've got the butler won a
little bonfire I can make that last over
soon as I'd submitted getting any day so
you weren't gonna bake yeah I mean don't
get me wrong I'm not criticizing the
budget why I dine at all I thought
certainly the January one was was very
good in the way it was presented but I
just felt that there was too much to
take in and as I said for some
councillors that was a struggle because
they hadn't had times but I cannot read
though to you those papers on that ipad
myself so they keep make a good point
though if you had the information early
enough and you know you've had an
opportunity to read through it again
okay okay it's trying to steal my phone
because I actually think okay yeah I
like to buy your new banana hold on you
but I think ma when a master there and
said can I have questions on that
morning when you ride the presentation I
said can we have this paper I boy I got
it do I not without input which are
paying attention probably not currently
I'm of the opinion that we should try
having the paper up front far earlier
yeah with the single day stick intercept
I'm very concerned as i said i'm
repeating i'm sorry i'm very concerned
lot of members will not be able to make
three saturday mornings or whatever and
they lose out totally we can only give
it gorgeous young master suite probably
what we have to remember is we've got
two separate away days and although
they've got the same tires on there
doing to it took quite different
functions and I'm more of you know it is
about what you think you might be able
to do if we were to have an additional
one it need to be fairly consecutive
with what one of the others because
we've got time tables to fit in for four
meetings and through our officers to do
the work and so on so I suspect that
having the the budget an additional
budget away they thrown in there would
actually for prove quite problematical
in terms of sequencing
obviously last year was quite different
it was as all sorts of clichés you can
use but it was shift change in the way
in which the budget away day was done
and there were some big budgeting issues
that we were addressing in the council
as a whole now I can't say that the
coming year wouldn't be any different in
terms of its intensity but the focus
might be able to be slightly different
you don't think I could set that point
Susan as you say it was difficult budget
this year and there's a lot of the
parameters coming into it in fact we
didn't even get the last budget proposal
to the day we actually decided on the
budget itself you know so that's that's
the sort of things that we're dealing
with here sorry in any way they can I it
was just do the thought that if there
was some and I'm sure there is a way in
which you know when people have the
paperwork that little bit earlier like
and then ask officers questions on that
for clarification just a strike Q&A
maybe that can they will at least be
more prepared for the questions on the
away I to be able to give the answers
and I think that's very unfair
realistically you know to expect them to
be able to off the cuff be able to
present something which they need to
research and that's most unfair well
it's not helpful even though the same
thing applies at the budget meeting
exactly like we actually are these
members to come forward we're quite
under so that it can be so you know
darling it's not me too we've got the to
budget way types albeit that they are
going to be slightly different each but
I mean ultimately they're going to come
together as one package so if there's
that week Grice beforehand or somewhere
beforehand where people can actually see
the issues that have been raised and
what is being presented and give them
the opportunity for some form of Q and I
so that they can actually put questions
forward to allow the officers to answer
them and prepare answers on the die and
that
like the flower the budget a wide I i
think a lot easier I'm not more sensible
and flogging so you know as I say to
spatially do what we do in the budget
meeting make sure that officers are
primed yes with any questions that may
require research I think that's how you
that's something to fear right over
there we called it was there is no joke
right any others yes please sir might I
didn't see it thought close to me we're
having the paper out earlier weird be
here but what do you fear system for
something was to have some sort of
guidance on how to interpret the
paperwork I understanding the paper
again well that's the way doe isn't it
well I'm okay just put for your
accountancy course it were the words of
caution end because the man requests it
requesting the the papers a week early
is fine but actually we're not
requesting the papers a week early we're
requesting that whole budget process
shunts forward a week and that's
actually going to bring some challenges
in itself so I do you think we need to
be aware of that with the ambition to
get the papers to members as soon as
possible that's it so I guys who study
as soon as possible to get points taken
at the fun it to vote points 0 and 1
just the recognition that actually we've
if it's a week earlier as counsel said
it won't read the most up-to-date data
so we will be presenting Aziz but
clearly we can thank you verbal updates
if things have materially changed it
will have a discussion and then secondly
I think I of the offer of any any member
who does one of discussion with me prior
to that on anything that they don't
understand I will happily sit and take
people through it I mine are active and
input totally awesome and so I won't do
it said it was temperature
yeah but that that will happen is if
mortgage in full training course Pitman
IT of what's going on I appreciate and
things change as well the financial
statements as well because the office
there of my tools open gate especially
right well having moved from the
calendar of meetings to the budget
usually everything moves to plan B but
that's not the store Pittsburgh but as
far as with the amendments that have
been proposed and the changes that have
been proposed ostensibly as I say will
go I think it's too is it does it go to
focus on someone go to an encounter the
main council meetings chairman but this
dis just sets the scene to start the
business going so might we that provides
our neighbors okay ready okay thank you
right so now we enter eager to read the
exclusion associate members of the
public you're ready to grow up and off
just I don't know you turnin acknowledge